fighting locally in louisiana as a
professional i was
wasn't making a lot of money but
sponsorships and um
you know people knew me there so we can
fill out arenas and make i can make a
little bit of money enough to
support me my wife because me and my
wife um
we've been married 12 years and we
bought a house when we were 19 years old
so i had a mortgage you know i had grown
man bills and i was a young kid trying
to fight and make money wow
you've been married 12 years yeah she's
in a bag yeah i saw your wife and a mac
that's cool married 12 years at 19 years
old you guys are still together that's i
mean what's the secret sauce there
you're all over every magazine every tv
everywhere how you making your marriage
work
i just got lucky and got the right one
you know she's my best friend and uh
i think i think i wouldn't have
accomplished a lot without her so
awesome
that's great
so
you have the first fight
sometimes if you're coming out and your
first bite kind of doesn't go your way
can psychologically mess with you did it
do anything to you or did the coach kind
of come back and say it's okay it's not
a big deal yeah here's the thing so i
thought
that the world extreme cage fighting was
a big organization it was on tv
um you know the championships were
respected and i was fighting on the
local scene i got a fight up in canada
and that's what got me signed to the wec
so i was so excited to go to vegas for
my first time you know traveling acro
across the country to fight nobody's
going to be on tv i get out there and i
lose and then i get my check and and i
thought i was gonna i was here i was
gonna make it life's about to change now
and then uh
medicals are deducted from my check my
my coaches flights are deducted for my
check
all these things and i'm
i can't survive on this when i got the
check i was making more money fighting
locally so it was a heartbreaking moment
for me wow
yeah so we got back home reevaluated
some things and just kept my foot on the
gas
but yeah that was a heartbreaker my
first loss as a professional how big was
the check can you was it a five ten
thousand twenty thousand dollars
i think i was making four thousand
dollars
to to show up the way fighting works
with mixed martial arts at the beginning
you get a show and a win if you win you
get the other half of your purse so i
was making like three or four thousand
dollars i lost so i didn't get the other
half
and then everything was deducted you
know as a young kid i don't know how
much flights really cost they're booking
i'm letting them book my my coaches
flights it's 600 dollars for his flight
you know
and i have a few coaches so i get my
check and i might have like 1200 bucks
and i got to fly back home and look at
my wife you know we didn't have money
for her to go
i didn't even have money to get the
hotel room you know
and um that's your first fight that was
my first loss as a professional so if
you like this sort of short clip from an
interview i did click over here to watch
the entire interview and
please don't forget to subscribe to the
channel take care everybody bye
[Music]
you